Kelly you've worked with Chris Nolan on
six films right what was it like getting
that call or having that conversation
with him we said we're doing Oppenheimer
and I want you to play him it was the
best you know you get a few of those in
your career that when you get the call
and like typical Chris it was no
Preamble nothing just just to call out
of the blue you know and uh it was it
was it was a gift a total gift and then
in classic Chris style he flew from LA
to give me the actual script you know he
never you never get anything on email it
has to give you the physical copy I just
tell you I'm doing Oppenheimer and you
are Oppenheimer exactly that voice you
don't have a choice in this matter
exactly that yeah yeah which is just
unbelievable yeah how about your
conversations with Chris he called me
and said you are not Oppenheimer
killing is and I said that makes sense
yeah and then uh yeah I went over his
house and read the script of like you're
saying it's uh amazing and then I got to
witness Killian's journey in segments as
I was coming into
to kind of play your antagonist and it
was
bananas we're able to to pick through
all the Nuance on that first read the
extraordinary thing about the script was
it's written in the first person right
which is the first time I'd ever
encountered to that so you you realize
then this is something different and you
know then he does this very clever thing
in the movie which you know the
Oppenheimer sequences are in uh color
and the straw sequences are in black and
white so it's kind of subjective uh
objective and that that's just amazing
yeah it's very cool
um Robert when you start to build this
character out and you shaved back the
hairline is it true that you thought
that you looked like your dad yeah I
look like my dad make sure I look like a
weird old angry owl
try not to chew up the scenery what did
Susan think of the shaved house she said
that's hot yeah no she said please uh
put on a uh a cap there were moments
where it felt sort of like a western
watching you walk through Los Alamos and
like like the gearing up of like the hat
and the pipe that was very considered an
oppenheimer's part you know it's
interesting because when we were doing
the the costume remember Chris sent me a
few pictures of David Bowie you know
like David Bowie and like you know kind
of thin white tube I like that I like
that reference uh Emily Blunt told us
that shooting this was kind of like
being at a summer camp it's unusual for
all the actors to be on location
together and we were shooting in this
really remote location in the middle of
the new Mexican desert and there was one
hotel and we were all together and that
doesn't happen normally everyone's in
their own place or you're shooting at
home or everyone's got their own house
and you don't hang out and there was one
restaurant that was it it was like the
dining hall you'd go in and you'd see
everybody and so everyone would just end
up sitting together did you guys have a
like a similar experience summer camp
she said yeah okay let me give a
Counterpoint
um you know what I I to agree with her I
would say that you have
pretty much a who's who of several
generations of of actors and we all know
we're doing something with a master
filmmaker and yet we're all there for
the love of it because this was a money
gig for none of us it was a
exceptionally taxing Venture and we'd
all do it again yeah if we could survive
it could you I don't know it was in
heroic effort watching him play this guy
man well I think you're very kind no I
think that I guess I get embarrassed
they were you know when we're shooting
in New Mexico there was a lot of the the
guys were like Emily and Matt and were
kind of living together I think they
were hanging out I was in the bath
learning lines yeah yeah studying very
very hard they were off gallivanting and
you were well he's like you know I'd
love to like party but I have to learn a
a lecture in Dutch yeah was there
somebody that either of you had not
crossed paths with personally or
professionally that you got to in this
film
or for me like working with Florence
pughes was amazing because she's she's
something else yeah and I've admired her
to work for a long time so that was a
real treat to get to work with yeah
everyone smashed it everyone turned off
and delivered every single actor there's
a big budget movie but did in that sense
it feel kind of like the camaraderie of
of an indie film where you're all coming
together for that for that common goal
to like to try to tell a great story on
on film I felt that for me how about you
yeah absolutely and even back to one of
your earlier questions even just like
getting to see and hang out with Matthew
Modine we had a lot of fun just hanging
around for sure but I think in terms of
the work
he it's such a a safe environment you
know to experiment and to try stuff out
and to kind of make a fool yourself and
and he creates this really kind of like
a laboratory and the other thing is I
was thinking about it no scene ever gets
left behind do you know what I mean no
scene is less important than another and
in addition to playing this Behemoth of
a role you hosted the experience for
everyone anytime someone was coming in
just to do a day you'd be there as
stressed out as you might have been next
thing you had to do was a you know a
bugger and yet you always took the time
I felt like you and Chris made me feel
welcome safe right at the beginning yeah
and that's not easy to do when you're
under duress you've seen the film right
yes you've seen an IMAX oh yeah what is
it like you don't get to yeah you're not
allowed you don't want your face that's
like everything you want okay three
stories high or whatever tall what is it
like seeing that his pores yeah I mean I
see they're on the medium
beautiful skin beautiful skin it is I
mean this you gotta see this I mean we
will because we're about to fly around
the world and have a lot of
opportunities to watch audiences see it
[Music]